So, what does this little
machine look like?
Remember, we're doing this to help R and
Ns memorize things better.
So let's forget about neural
networks for just a moment.
Imagine that you want
a system to have memory.
You need to do three things.
First, you need to write
the data into the memory.
Then you will be able to read it back,
and
then you also want to be
able to erase it, or forget.
Here is one way to write this
very same idea down as a diagram.
You have a memory,
which is maybe a matrix of values.
You also have inputs coming into
the memory, and a little instruction
gate that tells whether you are going
to write to that memory or not.
You also have another gate that's
says whether you are going to able
to read from that memory or not.
And then you have one final gate that
says forget the data or write it back.